there is grief and anger in Gaza eight
Palestinian migrants who died when their
boat sank of the Tunisian Coast in
October have finally been laid to rest
thousands of mourners came out to
support the families as they received
the bodies the young men were heading to
Europe in search of a better life
his father died when he was a child and
he said I will work and make up to you
all the years you spent raising me I
didn't want him to leave but he insisted
three of the victims Eunice Sammy and
Muhammad were members of a shire family
and 20 year old Maher is still missing
relatives say they were tricked by guns
and Smuggler who lives in France they
say he promised them safe passage to
Italy instead they crossed to Egypt then
Libya then in October six months after
the young men left the asshires lost
contact with their children
with Promises of work and a bright
future what they found was torture and
captivity they were beaten tortured and
robbed and in the end they died
Smuggler said they were in prison in
Libya but coast guards found the body of
Eunice's Shire plotting off Tunisia
the search was broadened and the others
were recovered the family is pleading
with authorities to keep searching for
Maher and to bring him home even if he's
in a coffin
after the suffering me and the other
families have seen and experienced in
the past months I say that staying here
for Thousand Years jobless is better
than migration and the torments it holds
and the price you pay
poverty is pervasive in Gaza the U.N
sells more than 80 percent of the
population relies on food assistance 15
years under an Israeli blockade has
destroyed the economy Import and Export
restrictions have led to the collapse of
both the private and public sectors and
although there are no official Statics
media reports suggest that more than 860
000 Palestinians left the Gaza Strip
between 2007 and 2021 and did not return
a generation especially of the young who
sees no future at home you may see it Al
Jazeera Gaza